now in the meantime as Christine Blasi
Ford and Brett Kavanaugh are testifying
before the Senate Judiciary Committee we
have a sworn affidavit from a third
specific accuser of Donald Trump's
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
who is alleging that he participated in
gang rape and the use of alcohol and
quaaludes on women in order to
ultimately perpetrate that gang rape the
first woman was christine Blasi Ford
who's testifying today the second was
Deborah Ramirez and now we have Julie
sweat Nick who has put out a signed
sworn statement who says that not only
Brett Kavanaugh but also his friend mark
judge who we still can't seem to get
subpoenaed and under oath were at a
party where sweat Nick was drugged and
gang-raped importantly sweat Nick
doesn't say that Kavanaugh is
specifically the guy who attacked her
but even her claims go directly counter
to Cavanaugh's claim that he he's just
never been to many parties where this
went on he didn't go to parties he
didn't drink no drugs no alcohol no gang
rape nothing he just has no idea he was
at being an altar boy in basketball camp
the entire time but sweat Nick
interestingly says that this was during
high school and that Cavanaugh was at at
least 10 parties which were also
attended by sweat Nick and again she
doesn't claim that Kavanaugh was her
attacker but she does say that she saw
Kavanaugh fondle and grab girls without
their consent tried to take their
clothes off without their consent and
she claims specifically that Kavanaugh
and Mark judge were in one of these
lines of men who would participate in
the gang rape of girls incapacitated by
alcohol or drugs Kavanaugh continuing to
take the deny deny deny approach he says
he's never met this woman it's all
concocted out of thin air he was a
virgin he didn't drink he doesn't know
anything about parties he was just doing
math equations the entire time that he
was in high school in college
saying quote this is ridiculous and from
the twilight zone I don't know who this
is and this never happened
think for a second what it would take
for this to be all a ruse okay someone
would have to start calling up women who
were at Yale and or in
Cavanaugh's high school at the same time
that he was there and I guess offering
the money right like in order to get
people to make these spurious claims I
guess you would say if you're willing to
come forward and say stuff about Breck
having I guess we'll give you money you
would need to make sure that the other
people who were with them in at Yale or
at the high school are not going to be
able to in a very clear way discredit or
say that couldn't possibly be true and
of course that would all need to be done
in secret right and at a certain point
you've got to apply Occam's razor if we
have two competing explanations that
explain something equally well we should
be skeptical of the explanation that
requires more assumptions we should say
all else being equal we should defer to
the explanation that is the simplest one
so compare explanation one right Brett
Kavanaugh assaulted women in high school
in college and those women are now
saying what happened to them and the mo
the storyline the behavior is the same
across all the stories
that's explanation one explanation two
would be someone went found and
convinced women who did go to Yale and
Cavanaugh's high school to lie about
what happened at the risk of their
personal lives being destroyed in the
midst of smears and harassment from the
right and it was done in such a
professional way that nobody figured out
who is finding these women who's funding
the operation to pay these women to make
these claims but that's very difficult
to believe right multiple women from
different times in Cavanaugh's life some
from high school some from college
telling a similar story Marc judges
ex-girlfriend tells a very similar story
of what judge would participate in it
just doesn't make any sense and and the
latest attempt at an exculpatory claim
from Kavanagh the calendar from June of
1982 which is riddled with you know he
was at beach week and then he was at
bball camp this is all just bizarre
right I mean first of all I guess it's
not impossible that you would keep a
calendar from 1982 of course maybe you
would do that if you need an alibi right
but but putting that aside I guess some
people do keep this type of
thing if I went to my mom's basement
right now if she hasn't thrown the stuff
out I might be able to find papers I
wrote in high school but do most high
schoolers even keep calendars like just
none of this makes any sense to me I
believe it's his calendar you know even
if he goes to like some specific party
where stuff like this is going on it's
not necessarily on the calendar it
doesn't prove or disprove anything it
does not yeah that's it I think that's
the point which is if the right wants to
focus on indisputable evidence a
calendar with things written on it is
also not indisputable evidence of
anything one way or the other and what I
want to go back to is the same thing
that I said yesterday during my story
about the hymn to movement about the
supposed you know
false sexual assault and rape
allegations against men if all of these
women are lying about Brett Kavanaugh
sue them sue them for defamation he
won't dare because then you would
actually adjudicate the truth or falsity
of the claims and it's clear Kavanagh
doesn't want that right and we're not
going to see that as I talked about
yesterday or at least support an FBI
investigation to look into all this
because I know that if I'm Cavanaugh and
I'm innocent of all of this and these
accusations are all false I want my name
cleared I don't want to just have the
vote rush through and to have this on my
record for the rest of my life
you wouldn't say about me let's get the
investigators who know how to do this
stuff to do the investigation but it's
not Cavanaugh who wants that it's
Christine Blasi Ford and it's the other
accusers I want to hear from you about
this make sure you follow the show on
instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram as well at david
pakman next my interview with Lacey
green one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an incredible online
learning community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation
and everything in between I think you'll
have no problem finding courses that are
perfect for you just took a really great
class on graphic design which I know
nothing about but I'm trying to learn
our show is giving you two entire months
of totally free access to every course
Skillshare offers risk free if you click
the link under this video you'll have
two months to take classes on anything
you're passionate about classes taught
by real people who share that passion
and after that you can keep getting
access to the entire site for less than
10 bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up